est ce toujours tu sais pas conduire
vous savez j'ai qu'un curé aveu je suis
devenu mon copain mais alors comme celle
qui me fait de la magie ça n'a rien à
voir sa cime simple invention ça tout le
monde peut le faire sauf lui peut-être
vania premier futur roi des 6000
je vais vous étés majesté aïeux moi
j'étais ya plus rien juste minable rien
d'un petit souci du un vrai rennais
c'est lui qui toi personne ne prendra
mon trône
il ya peut-être une solution
c'est qui cette bombe at celui-ci se
rencontraient dans le ciel est pas bon
soixante six mois sakai des portugais
thq et ça va on peut discuter comme moi
là bas vous et de votre numéro
ce pays semaines que je cours après tout
tu prends pour un kényan il s'indigne un
nouveau monde après il descend du tour
je veux changer notre façon de vivre 6 à
6,5 cette année on pas les crocs panique
alors comment elle plaisanté sont pas du
tout fondées que gillot
j'ai découvert la plus grande rue
couverte de tout ce temps j'ai découvert
après combinent sur mon chien